today we fight for our lives on April  27th  changes forever GRU put that thing away  Avengers infinity war rated pg-13 equal  27 the entire time I knew him he only  ever had one call  to wipe out half the universe if he gets  all the Infinity stones she seemed do it  with the snap of his fingers just like  that tell me his name again Santos  [Music]  we got one advantage  he's coming to us  we have a dannis once so that's what we  use  [Music]  let's talk about this plan here's I  think it's good except it sucks so let  me do the plan and that way it might be  really good  Wow  [Music]  the end is near  dun dun  [Music]  half of humanity will still exist  perfectly balanced  as all things should be  I hope that remember you  [Music]  I'm Peter valet dr. strange  oh you're using your made-up names then  I am spider-man  you  you